neo is a brutal action RPG that demands
you to understand its systems in order
to overcome its challenges but with so
many mechanics at play it can be
overwhelming
that's why we've gathered 10 tips to
help you become a master samurai if you
enjoyed this video be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more features on how to not die in neo
to see more of the game in action check
out our dual swords gameplay video
[Music]
make sure to keep a close eye on your
key gauge during battle avoid recklessly
swinging your weapon at opponents as
it'll quickly drain your key and put you
in in a mobile state this is indicated
by a red gauge and while in this state
you're vulnerable to enemy attacks if
this occurs mash the Dodge button to
ensure you get out of the way of danger
as soon as possible unlike the souls
games you can see how much key an enemy
has when you lock onto them
when an opponent completely drains their
key they'll either lack the energy to
move or attack more erratically take
advantage of this opportunity as enemies
are more susceptible to being staggered
when you hurt them in this state when an
enemy is staggered you have a better
chance of landing a powerful grapple or
final below as well it's also possible
to inflict direct damage to an
opponent's key using special skills that
are acquired via the learned skills menu
each weapon type has a particular
technique that can inflict key damage
for example the sword has a kick skill
which allows you to chain a kick at the
end of a combo to drain an opponent's
key prioritize unlocking these skills as
they can be vital in overcoming tough
encounters
[Music]
one of the most important mechanics in
neo is the key pulse a combat maneuver
that allows you to restore some of the
key you've expended from attacking to
execute it press r1 when light gathers
around you after an attack the better
you timed the key pulse the more key
you'll gain back key pulse is also a
necessity in purifying yokai realms
which are enemy attacks that reduce your
key regeneration rate within a certain
area a perfect key pulse can instantly
remove yokai realm from the field to
execute a perfect key pulse time your
button press to when the light is just
about to fade around you you'll know
when you've executed it when a swirling
light forms as you raise your weapon the
benefits of key pulse may not seem like
much at first but using it effectively
can make all the difference in battle
it's important to take advantage of the
various weapon stances as each add
useful attack variations to the weapons
in your arsenal there are three stances
in total high mid and low high stance
offers large attack damage and defense
against enemies but at heavy expense to
your speed and key midstance offers
medium attack speed and damage with some
cost to your key and low stance allows
you to attack quickly I'll be it weekly
with little expense to your key
familiarize yourself with the feel of
each stance and how they impact your
weapons of choice some stances prove
more useful than others during certain
encounters utilizing a swords high
stance allows you to slash vertically
which is ideal against enemies that stay
low to the ground a careful and
calculated understanding of weapon
stances is key to surviving the most
difficult battles neo has an internal
achievement system called titles which
allows you to earn additional stat
bonuses there are two achievement lists
in total audio and in Gil each offers
different challenges that demand you
fulfill distinct conditions for instance
the swordsmen adept title requires you
to defeat 100 human enemies with the
sword the more you diversify the types
of attacks you use including non weapon
attacks like throwing bombs the more
likely you'll earn a new title upon
earning a title you will receive
reputation points
once you've accumulated enough you'll
gain a prestige point which you can use
to acquire a stat bonus in the prestige
summary screen
each piece of armour you find has its
own distinct special effects that grant
you a variety of bonuses such as damage
reduction
elmerita bonuses and increased -
endurance however in order to access
them you need to meet the armored
statistical parameters which are listed
at the bottom of its description in the
equipment screen for instance the foot
piece of the warlord armor requires your
stamina to be at seven in your strength
at six be mindful of parameters when you
equip armor is not meeting them makes a
piece of armor only half as useful as it
could be while it might not seem
apparent at first there's actually an
equipment weight mechanic in the game
each piece of armor has its own weight
value which when equipped contributes to
your overall equipment weight percentage
note how the font color changes from
green to yellow at the top of the
equipment screen when you exceed a
certain weight the higher the percentage
is the more key your attacks and dodges
will consume your movement speed is also
affected understand your play style to
manage your equipment weight accordingly
if you value mobility staying at a
lighter weight is ideal but if you
prefer slow powerful weaponry stick to a
heavier weight it's important that you
never let your equipment weight exceed
100% as your attacks and evasive
maneuvers will consume nearly half your
key per action
[Applause]
when you explore an area keep an eye out
for Kodama which are small green yokai
that wear soup cups as hats
if you encounter a Kodama approach it
and hold circle to send it back to a
shrine for every 5 you collect you
increase the max number of elixirs you
can hold at a time in addition the
number you collect affects the
percentages of the Kodama blessings you
receive at a shrine
[Music]
collecting Kodama also gives you access
to their blessings which are passive
buffs that you can purchase at a shrine
each blessing is associated with a
specific type of Kodama there are five
types in total with five of each defined
in a region the more you collect of a
specific type the higher the percentage
its respective blessing will be it's
important to note that whenever you
reach a new region the Kodama blessing
percentage is reset this is because each
region has its own set of 25 Kodama to
collect
[Music]
there are two special support abilities
in the game ninjutsu and own mule jutsu
ninjutsu focuses on the use of throwable
items and inflicting status ailments on
enemies while oh no jutsu emphasizes
imbuing your weapon with different
elemental properties to take advantage
of enemy weaknesses both are incredibly
useful and each offers you an array of
options to supplement your offensive
efforts ninjutsu and omiyo jutsu
abilities are unlocked by spending
points via the learned skills menu in
their respective tabs once you've
acquired a ninjutsu or onmyo jutsu skill
you can then assign one to an item
shortcut by accessing the Redi jutsu
menu if there are any beginners tips
that I missed shouted in the comments
below and for more neo coverage
including our full review be sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
[Applause]
you